i realized he realized that how his
so-called friends were using him he
put his friends in check
he makes decisions for himself now
and my biggest thing with him before was
he had
everybody in his ear telling him what to
do
what i recently found out is anytime he
broke up with me it wasn't him messaging
me
it was somebody else writing it for me
yeah what
it's crazy but i'd rather keep them i'd
rather keep it i don't want to like talk
about it we're such a good spot but that
person's not in our life wait you gave
someone your phone
to text liz
and break up with her or tell her you
weren't interested or whatever it was
it was a little bit of both
that's pretty
them telling me that you you know she's
wrong for you she shouldn't be in your
life um here's what you need to say
here's here and and sometimes i would
ask for him to write it or
or
because i'm not that my grammar i'm not
that smart oh there's another guy damn
right you're not that smart
so you you're basically so lazy you're
like hey whoever you pay or stupid
enough to do for free is like hey can
you break up with my bra for me i just
turn left or i don't want to write a
long message and my grammar ain't too
good
this was then and this is six months
later where we're at now
oh my god
promise me don't marry him for a while
at least don't marry him we could have
already been married and we're not going
to you got to wake up
and you're not in love with her you're
using her you are desperate
who's not desperate
who's not desperate everybody knows that
you don't think ed is in love with liz
oh hell no
no one can tell you who to love no one
knows what th what's in your how do you
know what's in my heart you don't love
anybody except yourself liz were you
aware that he was those six months while
he's getting his brain together that he
was out sniffing around for somebody
that would appreciate him and say yes
the only reason he wasn't with those
women is because they turned him down
but he's single i'm single nope
i think get up and he was blasted all
over the internet for it he came back
crying and he gave her the biggest gift
he could think of and that is an
engagement and that's how he got her
back
yep
it's basically a bribe
[Music]
you